this program is brought to you by Emory
University I think there'll be some sort
of agreement reached before the
expiration of authority to borrow
additional money by the federal treasury
and that effectively runs out the first
week in August it's possible that there
will be a longer term agreement of
around two trillion dollars in deficit
reduction but I think it's likely that
they may agree to some shorter extension
of the debt ceiling that would require
that the two parties come back together
at some point before the 2012 election
both parties are serious about resolving
the deficit problem i think but they
have fundamentally different ideas about
the path to do that and both are also
cautious about getting in a position
that's going to be disadvantageous for
the 2012 election cycle it's possible
that we might have some larger budget
reform package enacted after the next
presidential election I think one
historical analogy maybe to think about
the conflicts of the budget back in the
1990s and we had a very intense debate
and some confrontation some government
shutdowns when we had divided government
between the Republicans in Congress and
President Bill Clinton but it took
ultimately about two years for an
agreement to get worked out and didn't
come until after the 1996 presidential
election was a very big budget agreement
it was enacted in 1997 which set the
budget on course to being balanced in
the late 90s in some ways divided
government allows the parties to reach
an agreement to sort of hold hands and
jump together whereas it's it's
sometimes a tough task for a single
party to take on responsibility for a
big budget reform like this and the
reason for that is that the only way to
reduce the deficit is by delivering bad
news it's either increases in taxes or
reductions in spending and benefits that
government
divides to citizens and the politics of
that are tough regardless of which
direction that the reform package got
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University